and well she is responsible for
delivering treats to troops all over the
world
and she's back at it once again despite
the pandemic
we are talking about a local chef whose
efforts we've profiled for
many many years here kirsten joyce
joining us now with how this year is
shaping up for our chef
kirsten it's shaping up well considering
that chef brenda villatora went into
retirement last year but that didn't
last long she came right back out when
she realized she just didn't want to
have any
active service members miss a taste of
home in the holidays
during this pandemic this is a labor of
love
nobody makes any money everything goes
into making
the cookies with the volunteers with
the schools chef brenda started cookies
for troops 13 years ago and to date
she's baked more than 140
000 it started in the kitchen of the
cordon blue then
and this year csn allowed her to use its
kitchens to get the baking done
chef brenda sends love in every package
as troops are enjoying the goodies they
can read letters written by school kids
and
laugh at the little jokes they send her
goodies have been sent
all over the world we're talking kuwait
djibouti baghdad they've been everywhere
these cookies in the capable hands of
brigadier general u.s air force max j
stitzer
and he's going to make sure that our
active member
forces are going to get a taste of home
this holiday season
now during years past chef brenda got a
lot of help from marine riders of las
vegas
bringing the christmas elves they
dressed up and
she and mr claus visited the va hospital
delivering sweet goodies to the veterans
with a little christmas cheer and once
again she says now with kovid she fears
the world has
changed and people are afraid she says
she knows it's just temporary but
it made her want to get these cookies
out more than ever this year